Obama is in the fits into the largest
group of presidential poker players that
is people who play for very low stakes
to relax with friends to meet simple as
part of their political cronyism he
arrives in 1997 and the Springfield
State veil and I sent it in Springfield
not knowing too many Illinois
politicians you know he's as tall thin
University of Chicago Law Professor he's
a writer kind of an egghead and part of
his effort to to get along with
downstate soybean farmers and Chicago
Ward bosses was to start a poker game in
the basement of his fellow freshman
senator Terry link and they invited
Republicans and they invited fellow
Democrats and lobbyists and it was just
it was called the committee meeting and
it was a chance once a week for six or
seven hours to get to know the people
that he had to do business with for the
rest of the week in Springfield